welcome to this video playing katsu more
22 from from Norway and let's see what
what happens in this game the only good
thing about this may be this this
ratings slump is I get some other
opponents being am being lower rated may
be quite interesting from time to time
okay let's see we have a modern defense
IAM okay i'm not sure ever played this
right h3 there are there are ideas like
that but maybe not here okay taking the
chance to put something in the center
hmm Joe it looks okay for white on this
Terrace yep exactly something that
something directly that tries to use my
weekend weekend g3 square but I was
thinking that maybe I can really just
take the pawn now come on I just take
the point
jive have six possibly on or long
castles now maybe castling no he cannot
cast on now probably he needs to take
now or allow me six
yeah Knight takes d5 so I mean if
everything else fails I'll take twice
take a seven now this is not listen up
badly okay hmm he's attacking my rook um
question is though do I need to attend
to that if I flick in Bishop g5 let's do
this quince where does he go what I'm
getting at is if he goes Quincy seven I
can play e6 maybe this is strong ii 6f
Bishop f6a Bishop f4 sorry you should
have form
taking the rook I'll take d7 and wind
Weeden right away it was even a maid fe
Bishop f4 had just just winds at peace I
will live on or some other heavy
material maybe you can play takes Bishop
f4 Bishop age 67 very weird move across
pin but I just but I just I can just
take the bishop on age 6 he apps he
cannot cannot he can take age one but
it's not going to survive that it would
be amazing if this is possible
I will know some way to confine you
forfeit due to this connection okay I
don't think there is any move it's a
it's a it's a flat win this was the only
thing that briefly were at me but the
problem is that the night is basically
trapped I can also can just play here by
by the way just attacking if he retreats
when i win the peace with their with a
very good position yeah was just it's
just overwhelming I really not sure
maybe this this wasn't a great idea
night h5 he's just not very well
developed Bishop g7 long castles yeah
maybe you should play this I mean II I
was thinking that this is check this is
possible if everything else fails but
it's not that terrible for Black Keys
got control over you five and let's say
something like this is certainly
something that black can play it's not
it's not losing um however if we look at
this this also Queen f2 now that's
that's pretty good yeah the queen is
attacked and I have this very nice place
for the bishop that's a very good
position now yeah this is what I should
should do then not sure if I would have
done it but maybe I would have before
the end game and keep it safe but this
looks looks good okay thanks for
watching